welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it looks like
we have some more indication about the
way that the Sony and Disney deal is
going with two full statements from Tom
Holland and Kevin Feige if you've been
keeping up to date with the channel then
you'll know that on Friday we reported
that cosmic book news had listed an
entire breakdown of the new Disney and
Sony deal and this was backed up by a
post on Tom Hollands Instagram that
showed a photo of him and Robert Downey
jr. with the caption we did it mr. stock
the deal was rumored to be appearing at
d23 this weekend however as of now
nothing has materialized and this has
left many people asking questions
especially of Tom Holland who is present
at a panel Holland initially said it's
been a crazy week but I want you to know
I love you all from the bottom I heart I
love you 3,000 this was pretty vague but
since then he and Kevin Feige have step
forward and both given more details on
what is happening in an exclusive
interview with E W com Holland had the
following to say basically we've made
five great movies it's been five amazing
years I've had the time of my life who
knows what the future holds but all I
know is that I'm going to continue
playing spider-man and having the time
of my life it's going to be so fun
however we choose to do it the future
for spider-man will be different but it
will be equally as awesome and amazing
and we'll find new ways to make it even
cooler so it seems as if the deal is
still undecided and Kevin Feige -
followed this up by saying I'm feeling
about spider-man gratitude and joy we
got to make five films within the MCU
with spider-man two standalone films and
three with the Avengers it was a dream
that I never thought would happen it was
never meant to last forever we knew
there was a finite amount of time that
we'd be able to do this and we told the
story we wanted to tell and I always be
thankful for that
honestly this feels like a huge step
back and seems rather downtrodden
however there are several sources
stating that the deal is still in
negotiations and those who remember the
build-up to Civil War will recall that
Feige stated that spider-man would not
be appearing in the film before the news
was fully confirmed Holland states who
knows what the future holds
perhaps hints that not everything is
completely closed off however from a
realistic point of view and taken at
face value this does not seem like a
positive way to address what's going on
I do think it's weird that foggy says
that they told the story that they
wanted to even though the movie ended on
a cliffhanger and they set spider-man up
as the next Iron Man which he now could
potentially not be though I may be
reading too far into this there are
rumors floating around that Disney had
proposed a 70/30 split with Sony after
initially rejecting Sony's first counter
offer which was 25% so if they can close
the gap then we could potentially see an
update on this in the next week or so
though of whether it comes to fruition
remains to be seen honestly it's so back
and forth at the moment with every new
source including myself getting
different tidbits from insiders and
posting bearing reports so I'm glad that
Feige in Holland sort of released this
statement even if it's slightly an on
statement that still leads to more
questions than answers this is a lot of
spin that doesn't really give too much
away about the future but rather focuses
on the past whilst negotiations are
still up in the air but one thing that
we can take from this is that we will
definitely be getting more spider-man
movies with Tom Holland though which
studio they are under remains to be seen
personally at this point a thing that
year the company would be stupid to
break the partnership and even if Disney
went back to the original 5% deal over
time they would probably still make more
money by having the character in the
crossover films than they would without
him it's what's best for the fans that
ultimately makes the corporation's money
and they are definitely better together
than they are apart this is its own
little civil war and whilst it's
heart-wrenching to see the
back-and-forth at least it's keeping us
glued to the news for any new details
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this and what you take from the
statements so comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out the updated deal that was reported
by cosmic book news which would be
linked at the end I'll be reporting on
all of the d23 updates as they happen so
make sure you stay lock of the channel
if you love marble 3000 if you want to
come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the per
places suggest new videos and content
also just wanna let you know that we're
giving away a free copy of John Luke
three and blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is to
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the Sony Disney situation
and the comments section below the
winner will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blu-ray will
be shipped out from then - if I get
surprised it's the best of luck that
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you